SEE YOU TOMORROW
>> Tucker: WELL, GOOD EVENING
AND WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSSON.
AND A CARAVAN IS TRAVELING
ACROSS MEXICO TONIGHT.
MEX AN AUTHORITIES ARE SPEEDING
THEM TO THEIR DESTINATION WHICH
IS OUR COUNTRY.
THEY ARE NOT REFUGEE.
THEY HAVE NO LEGAL RIGHT TO COME
HERE AND THAT IS ABOUT THE SUM
TOTAL OF WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
THEM.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THEY HAVE
SKILLS OR GANG MEMBERS OR SPEAK
ENGLISH.
THEY KNOW IF THEY CAN CROSS THE
BORDER IN TO CALIFORNIA, THEY
ARE SET.
DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS WILL GIVE
THEM BENEFITS AND THEY CAN GO
ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY JUST
LIKE MILLIONS OF THEM.
IF YOU WONDER WHY AMERICA IS NOT
LIKE THE COUNTRY YOU GREW UP IN.
WILL ANYONE IN POWER DO GOING TO
PROTECT AMERICA THIS TIME OR
WILL LEADERS SIT PASSIVELY BACK
AS THE INVASION CONTINUES.
THE PRESIDENT SENT A SERIES OF
TWEETS, ACT NOW, CONGRESS HE
TWEETED.
OUR COUNTRY IS BEING STOLEN.
TO THAT, OFFICIAL WASHINGTON
SCOFFED.
HOW DARE THE LEADER OF THE
COUNTRY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
TOMORROW WHO COMES HERE.
JIM SCHUMER WHO POSES AS
A JOURNALIST IN CNN.
>> AS OFTEN HAPPENS WITH ISSUES
LIKE THIS.
IT IS A FACT FREE ZONE.
YOU HEARD THAT FOX NEWS
RHETORIC.
AN ARMY OF MIGRANT.
IT IS A GROUP OF FOLKS WHO ARE
SEEKING A SYLUM.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED CARAVANS
AND MULTIPLE OF PEOPLE STORMING
THE BORDER IT IS NOT TRUE.
>> Tucker: IT IS MORE PROPAGANDA
FROM THE OBAMA PEOPLE SEEKING TO
BE REPORTERS.
CNN IS THE LEFT VIEW AS WELL.
IS IT AMERICA'S VIEW AND DO
VOTERS THINK WE HAVE A MORAL
OBLIGATION TO ADMIT EVERY PERSON
IN THE WORLD XH ANY TIME THEY
WANT TO COME AND FEED AND HOUSE
AND EDUCATE AT OUR EXPENSE.
THE BOATERS THINK THAT.
JISZICCA IS THE FRANCISCAN IS
JOINING US.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
WHEN THE OBAMA GUY SAID THEY ARE
SEEKING A SYLUM.
DOES THAT MEAN WE CAN DO NOTHING
ABOUT THIS?
>> IF THEY ARE SEEKING A SYLUM
GO SEEK IT TO MEXICO IN THIS
CASE.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS IS.
THIS IS A POLITICAL STUNT
DESIGNED TO CHALLENGE THE UNITED
STATES AND IN PARTICULAR THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS ORGANIZED BY ACTIVIST
AND A WALKATHON BY OPEN BORDERS.
THEY RECRUITED THE PEOPLE TO
JOIN THIS GROUP AND MAKING THEIR
WAY TO THE UNITED STATES AND IT
IS A PUBLIC RELATIONS STUNT AND
A CHALLENGE TO OUR SOVEREIGNTY.
AND THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO MEET
THE CHALLENGE AND NOT JUST CARRY
ON THE WAY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION DID AND WELCOME
THEM IN.
WE DON'T NEED TO ACCEPT THEIR
APPLICATION.
THEY ARE TRAINED ON HOW TO
COMMIT A SYLUM FRAUD.
>> Tucker: WHY WOULD IT BE
A THOUSAND PEOPLE OR 300000.
OR WHOLE POPULATION OF SAL
VADOR.
THE TWO-THIRDS THAT DON'T
ALREADY LIVE HERE?
POPULATIONS IN POOR COUNTRIES
ARE EXPLODING.
AND WHAT EXACTLY IS OUR RECOURSE
WHEN THAT DOES HAPPEN?
WHAT DO WE DO TO PREVENT THAT
FROM HAPPENING.
>> WE HAVE TO PREVENT IT FROM
HAPPENING NOW.
THIS IS BUILDING TO THE POINT
SINCE THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
CHANGED THE RULES ON A SYLUM AND
FRIENDLY JUDGES STEPPED IN AND
SAID YOU CAN'T DETAIN KIDS AND
ONE THING WE CAN DO IS PREVENT
THEM FROM GETTING TO THE UNITED
STATES.
AND DO AS WE HAVE DONE IN THE
PAST AND UNTIL MEXICO WE WANT TO
COME IN AND HEAD THIS OFF BEFORE
THEY GET TO OUR BORDER.
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF LEVERAGE
WITH MEXICO ON MIGRATION ISSUES.
IT IS NOT THEIR JOB TO CONTROL
THEIR BORDER AND WE MAKE IT IN
THEIR INTEREST TO PREVENT THINGS
LIKE THIS FROM HAPPENING.
LET'S FACE IT.
MEXICO GETS A LOT MORE OUT OF
OUR BILATERAL RELATIONSHIP THAN
WE DO.
WE NEED TO USE THAT LECHERAGE
AND MAYBE KIND MUCH TIE IT IN TO
NAFTA IF WE HAVE TO.
BUT WE DON'T NEED TO JUST SIT
BACK AND STAND BY WHILE PEOPLE